the suspect hardly is it
[Music]
our officers at the door
shudder both officers are they super
both officers suffered fatal wounds our
officers did not draw the weapons did
not fire and never stood a chance so
Saturday two police officers were
ambushed and killed in Texas their names
elder Miro Garza age 45 and Ishmael
Chavez 39 responding to a domestic
disturbance in the effort to stop
violence they became its victims that's
the story of many officers lives we
report it on this show because we
realized the proportion of media
coverage on such crimes compared to
other stories is obviously lacking when
a violent act occurs that fits a
narrative it's amplified to suit the
media's needs what need does it serve to
report a story of two Ted officers for
the rest of the media very little so
they shrug it off but Fox News won't
today we're living in an experiment one
conducted by mad social scientists where
a media and its Internet platforms
choose stories that manipulate emotion
for the sake of clicks they put a price
on rage and they sell it by the minute
so the bravery and hardships of law
enforcement are ignored in favor of
visual content untethered to data but
tied to a narrative in 2020 ironically
the media refuses to clearly see the
truth of policing instead pushing
stories that alarm and divide citizens
this rift is now energizing violent
criminals as Democrat mayors and other
politicians follow the same path
deserting law and order and therefore
you and they laugh at those who now try
to protect themselves
politicians are scared of the mob scared
of the media as both cheer mayhem over
peace officers and if you cheer the
police your maid and unperson by the mob
go ahead say blue lives matter and see
what happens to you so even if you
haven't read or well you'll get to live
it how long will we endure this until we
decide enough is enough
so we report this story not to make you
angry or sad but to help you decide when
enough is enough
so Katie Savannah Chavez is the daughter
of one of the slain officers and she
went on Twitter and tweeted her her
sorrow and with a hashtag of blue lives
matter which withdrew attacks and
mockery and ridicule including a BLM
blue checker who called the the hashtag
racist so she actually deleted it after
mourning her own dad all of this seems
kind of an inevitability in a climate
where we paint people who try to protect
our our safety as the problem yeah and I
think that's why the situation is so
frustrating because logic and facts and
mourning police officers who made the
ultimate sacrifice to try and break up a
domestic dispute is somehow now racists
even though of the police in this
situation were minorities you know this
is a consequence of the current
situation the current rhetoric and
people giving in to this idea a
politician specifically that it is okay
to engage in policy decisions based on
this mob mentality of the demands that
they are given you know police we can
say all day long go out there every
single day to sacrifice themselves and
we see it and I think that the country
will come to a point where enough is
enough again it's a scary situation
because we look at the st. Louis couple
who dared to defend their private
property with firearms when there was a
mob on their front lawn they're now
being prosecuted by the the far-left
prosecutor in that town in that city so
that's a problem but at some point
people are gonna have to vote out the
people making decisions based on this
mob mentality and stand up for what is
right and to stand up for the rule of
law because there's no other way to
really do it yeah Dana so far your
year-over-year this weekend in New York
we saw six hundred six hundred percent
increase in shooting six hundred percent
and a four hundred and eighty three
percent in shooting victims but AOC has
a theory on why this is the case and I
want to play this and get your response
do we think this has to do with the fact
that there's record unemployment in the
United States right now maybe this has
to do with the fact that people aren't
paying their rent and are scared to pay
their rent and so they go out and they
need to feed their child and they don't
have money so you maybe have to they're
put in a position where they feel like
they either need to shoplift some bread
or go hungry that night
so Dana Yuma you must when you hear this
must think how ironic and bizarre it is
that she is blaming violence on
unemployment giving her given her role
in creating actual unemployment yes and
we are thinking alike even in a pandemic
you know something that might help
unemployment might be an Amazon Center
that was actually pandemic years right
Amazon is doing great in the pandemic
and you know the violence that we're
talking about is not like a mother
huddling with a loaf of bread under her
coat like Jean Valjean and lamia's are
robbed that is not the kind of violence
that we're talking about and it was just
two weeks ago that the City Council of
New York City voted to defund the police
by a billion dollars oh that's working
out really well and to your point about
the media coverage the painting of the
black lives matter mural which is really
I don't why we call it a mural but it's
a sign it says black lives matter it's
three words that got so much media
attention and where has have you seen
bill de blasio
anywhere talking about any of this it is
so unfortunate the other thing I wanted
to point out and the reason I was really
interested in that case in Texas with
the officers being ambushed is that one
of the things we heard a lot about and
talking about police reform is that some
communities think that it would be
better to send a social worker to
domestic violence trains because that
way you're not getting in the ball
you're not hauling away a father well
one of the reasons that you have to send
an officer is because it's often because
it's a place of violence and you're
trying to protect the women and the
children
are in harm's way so I don't think that
the social worker thing is going to work
on its own if you want to send a social
worker along with the officers fine but
know that their lives could be in danger
as well yeah why it's a to Dana's point
you know with the black lives mural or
painting we have a media that is so
focused on symbolism as opposed to the
actual reality which is what occurred
Saturday you know two men were lost and
that mural wouldn't save them well I
think the mural really represents what
the nation saw in a video where a police
officer was kneeling on a man's neck for
nearly nine minutes and the man died
correct so I think people are reacting
to that and I think in general police
have a dangerous and stressful job my
condolences go out to those officers who
died their families but it's more
stressful when they have the added
scrutiny of police officers abusing the
public trust and public authority and
people are dying then people start to
question logically exactly what the
police are doing so at the moment I
think what we're seeing is even in a
more stressful situation added to the
George Floyd pressure because we have
this spike in crime but let me just say
the spike in crime is almost solely
solely in black and brown neighborhoods
low-income communities in New York
Chicago I could go on and what you
really have to deal with here is the
problem of gangs drug dealers domestic
abuse in some cases that leads to this
spike in violence and of course the easy
access to guns but if we really care
about this loss of life I think we have
to deal with the systemic issues which
are on display you know everything from
the bad schools to the you know
inability for people to get good food to
the poor quality in general of life in
those communities that a kid doesn't
have a chance in many cases to succeed
or doesn't feel that way anyway I don't
even think the culture is terrible in
terms of the music that's my thing and
I'd say black lives matter should be at
the forefront of
that movement as well they should be
saying don't allow black lives matter to
simply be about the police but black
lives matter should be about how black
people treat each other so I think on
all those levels we have to just be
honest this is not a citywide crime
spree anywhere this is something that's
happening in our most desperate
communities all right so Jessie Wan
mentions a lot of variables however
those variables existed before this
massive spike so clearly something else
is added on to this that has that has
little to do with those other variables
yeah we know eight that is and I want to
salute Juan for saying what he said I
agree with almost everything Juan just
said the the thing I would add is that
you know a lot of the problems in these
cities where you're seeing a lot of the
carnage
they've been run by Democrats for 50
years and we've been seeing the same
thing again and again and again so maybe
if we change the systemic problems we
have to change the person or people that
are running that system in terms of the
media the media Greg that they don't
report the news they just report a
narrative that's why half the country is
either angry or unenlightened because
they're not getting the truth and that's
why people come to Fox to hear the truth
and the truth is there's a crime wave
going on in New York City homicides are
up 25%
Kansas City's had its most deadly year
ever
Chicago deadliest year so far in 25
years and I can keep naming cities we
had a white mom killed after she said
all lives matter in Indianapolis
there was a Hispanic man that drove his
truck and murdered a white guy because
he says he hates white people and hates
Donald Trump he was charged with a hate
crime there's stuff like this all over
the place I came back to the city the
other week down in lower Manhattan
there's a whole black lives matter
encampment by City Hall
you can't jog near there you can't walk
your dog you can't run a stroller it
smells worse than San Francisco and
they've desecrated architectural
masterpieces some of the architecture
some of the buildings in that area just
vandalized with graffiti that says F the
pigs are F the cops it's horrible so the
Democrats thought they could ride this
wave of energy to November and win I
think that's absolutely wrong I think
this wave became a crime wave it's gonna
blow up in their face people are dying
and it's going to destroy their cities
which are their power centers because
everyone's just fleeing and leaving them
in tatters